[Music]
you know people ask me jeremy how do you
avoid copyright strikes
having zero tone when you sing there's a
pretty good way to do it
i guess we'll see so mortal kombat so
this mortal kombat movie is a new mortal
kombat movie it's the first
live-action mortal kombat movie we've
had since mortal kombat annihilation
don't know what that says other than
hollywood not really having a lot of
faith in mortal kombat there have been
other live-action mortal commas we had
mortal kombat rebirth which became
mortal kombat legacy seasons one and two
mortal kombat conquest represent bam
it's kind of a weird flex whatever it
came out at like midnight it was
summer school was out i would watch it
everyone else was in bed
i've always been a night owl that's just
me so now we have new mortal kombat
which
really it's not mortal kombat yet it's
like the prequel to mortal kombat
a prequel to a new mortal kombat not the
1995 movie mortal kombat
also titled mortal kombat and this
mortal kombat prequel titled mortal
kombat will lead into the mortal kombat
tournament
titled mortal kombat anyhow they did
kind of bum me up because i like the
tournament i like the tournament
logistics i like a world of rules i like
the fact that it's like oh no
outworld is trying to invade earth
realm's trying to hold them off
but there are rules you know they can't
just kill off people that there's a
tournament and this movie was kind of
weird because i guess you
can just send sub-zero out there to
start killing people if they're going to
take place in the tournament
i half expected raiden to come down in
his
thunder and be like my sideshow freaks
attacked my fighters
that is expressly forbidden before the
tournament but not here though here he'd
be like your psycho freaks attacked my
fighters
which is kind of how it happens in this
movie
completely within the rules keep your
head on a swivel
be prepared they might try to kill you
in your house
i'm kind of getting ahead of myself
first of all this movie starts out
amazing because it starts out with a
scorpion sub-zero backstory and that
backstory like
that was a hard hook for me back in the
day when i was a kid and if you're one
of those mortal kombat fans are clocking
into this movie for the blood
the blood and gore is here too quite a
few fatalities death blood everywhere
rated r because they're like everyone
who watched the pg-13 mortal kombat
movie they're all
40 now at least it's fine and some of
the characters in this movie are good
and great there's a contrast the
contrast between
wooden and boring and quite literally
[ __ ] amazing that contrast is all
here with mortal kombat character even
in the middle you have the ones that are
like yeah they're good like sonia and
jax i thought they were good the two
standouts for me you would think of
scorpion
scorpion's not really in this movie as
much as the trailer might have alluded
to him being in this movie so
sorry that the trailer kind of lied to
you but sub-zero i thought sub-zero was
badass they did some great things with
sub-zero including but not limited to
some horror movie elements like people
be hanging out you'll see
fractals growing on the window you know
it's all getting icy it's like oh my god
he's coming and it answers that very
simple question we've been asking for
decades what would it look like if
sub-zero attacked a family out of
mcdonald's here we go
we've all kind of wanted to see that
right mortal kombat characters
in the real world with their magic
abilities and yeah they'll blow some
minds so it's kind of cool to see that
but sub-zero was hardcore and he's
behind sub-zero
so you know he's a dick and the number
one the standout dude kano
give it up volcano slow clap for kano i
thought kano
in a word in this movie is kano
i thought he was completely the soul of
the character
and he kind of made the movie he's
talking [ __ ] he's talking [ __ ] well he's
disrespecting
any and all characters he can this kano
in this movie is a complete dog
and i love him for it and this movie has
some solid fights but again with the
contrast there are some fights that are
quite literally amazing and some fights
were i was like that was kind of shoddy
and quick and
that's it kind of a bummer this movie is
all about contrast between good and bad
this movie definitely has some give and
take
though i think every mortal kombat
adaptation has give and take it's like
every mortal kombat thing
ever except the story in mortal kombat
9. i still think that's the
quintessential mortal kombat story
all right some fun fights some great
gore some good fatalities that you will
recognize also some fan service where
you're like
i didn't expect to see that reference
for that character
that was fun that's there for the fans
but all right in a world of talking
about characters going back to kano
if it wasn't for kano i probably would
have been bored in this movie because a
lot of the
characters i didn't feel that synergy
with them they might have been fine on
their own but you do need that team
synergy and whatever the flaws that the
mid-90s the original mortal kombat movie
has whatever cheese is in there one of
the things it did right was it had that
feeling of synergy that feeling of a
team between sonia
liu kang and johnny cage this movie
doesn't really have that
feeling it's more or less kano and other
people kane win the generics
kano and the boars are being a little
harsh because to be fair i did like
sonia and jax but really
coal is the forefront here coal is the
chosen one
i'm not above a mortal kombat adaptation
creating new characters out of the blue
even though there's
nearly a hundred characters to pick from
inexisting lore but dude i just flashed
my mortal kombat conquest
series dvd that made [ __ ] up so i'm not
above it but the bummer is
cole's not that interesting his
character is just kind of boring he's a
bit
wooden also liu kang and kung lao in
this movie
and they're boring too i don't know if
boring's a word definitely
i'd say generic they feel like generic
support characters
just came out of the blue they're kind
of pushed to the side and again they're
not that interesting i mean they have
their superpowers that make them them
from the game what doesn't make them
interesting it just means they're
generic people with superpowers so the
problem i have with them making this
character coal up and making him the
center of attention here is that if
you're gonna make a new character
up at least iron out the legacy
characters who have earned
that spot but they didn't they pushed
the legacy characters to the side to
make room for this guy
who's not that interesting that's
probably not a good thing to do
and i've seen this argument out there
and if you're one of these people if
you're in this
boat then you're probably going to be
fine with it but i've seen people be
like dude this mortal kombat just give
me the blood give me the fights i am
good but that's
not how i am with mortal kombat i guess
there are two camps of mortal kombat
fans gore before
lore and lore before gore it's all about
which one you are and although
the gore and the blood was a nice hook
for young me i was like
look at that the reason i stuck around
with mortal kombat was because the
characters and the lore were next level
amazing i had not seen storytelling like
this in a fighting game ever so since
mortal kombat 1 i just kept with it
all my life not always the smoothest
storytelling a lot of retcons a lot of
retcons to the retcons when people die
they never stay dead they always come
back and it makes you feel like there
aren't a lot of stakes in mortal kombat
but
man i love that lore so it's not just
fights in blood the story and the
characters of mortal combat is a
big piece of it for me this is way
better than annihilation
let's just say that now let's just get
that out of the way so there's
no mincing words here but annihilation
did do that thing where it's like here's
a mortal kombat character
you get no backstory with them but you
know it's the anyhow
they're here to fight that's why they're
here soul reason
this movie does do that although in this
movie they give the good grace to
actually name them but there's one in
particular who fights
jax at the end where i'm like that
character could have been anybody
at all i mean i dig the reference
because i don't think this character
gets enough love
it's a deep cut to be sure but he had no
lines he just growled he fought jax and
that was that like
he was just here to fight in the world
where every mortal kombat character has
so much lore attached to them like
fans will feel that loss regardless this
movie definitely does
end on a high note and that end fight is
[ __ ] epic it's business this is a
weird wrap-up for me because it's like
this movie is the calm before the storm
the storm being the tournament which is
really what i care about with mortal
kombat this wasn't quite there yet but i
think it behooves mortal kombat fans to
check this movie out one because
i mean if you're a mortal kombat fan you
kind of have to you just give this a
pass but i do hope this movie gets
support from fans because i want to see
the next step i think the
vision is there i want to see this
vision in the mortal kombat tournament
this movie has
a really good tone to it i love the tone
i love the vibe
this is the mortal kombat tone that i've
wanted to see for a while one could
argue forever i think with some better
writers and some character refinement
making the characters more interesting
that could be a kick-ass mortal kombat
movie this movie wasn't quite there yet
there is fun to be had in it but i want
to see the next movie
if that makes sense and it's probably
more fun if you're drunk
yeah now it's some mortal kombat
alright so mortal kombat the new mortal
kombat that's a prequel to mortal kombat
that we don't have yet which will
probably be called
mortal kombat also have you seen it
probably not i think it came out in
europe already but
it doesn't come out on hbo max until
this friday hbo max or theaters however
you want to watch it after you do watch
it tell me what you think whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see
[Music]
more
you